[Musique]
des maisons tourangel dévastées et un
appareil ferroviaire en ruine des corps
d'apocalypse pour les tourangeau qui se
réveille ce 20 mai
1944 la nuit précédente 500 bombes ont
été larguées sur la ville par les
Anglo-Américains cette nuit Claude
croubois en a gardé le souvenir intact
13 ans à l'époque des faits et avec
l'insouciance de l'adolescence on
restait aux fenêtres pour regarder parce
que cétait un spectacle féérique les
avions lançaient des fusées éclairantes
hein c'est on aurait cru un formidable
feu d'artifice la DCE allemande tirait
ça faisait aussi des des traînées
lumineuses voilà
et comme d'habitude on s'est dit on va
regarder parce que on savait bien que
c'était pas pour nous la rue boord entre
la rue girudeo et la rue du chevalier
c'était pas un objectif stratégique et
pour cause les Américains n'ont qu'une
cible le dispositif F Rère de tour
Saint-Pierre DESC situé en partie dans
les quartiers actuels du Sanitas et de
la
retonde Tour est un ferroviaire avec une
grosse infrastructure ferroviaire une
gare de marchandises répartie sur deux
communes tour et saint-pierredcor et en
passant par le le croisement ferroviaire
de tour les Allemands avaient la
possibilité de faire monter des troupes
très rapidement ainsi que des des
blindés sur la côte normande et donc les
Américains par anticipation on
souhaitait rompre ces lignes
d'approvisionnement mais les bombes sont
larguées à 5000 m d'altitude et selon
cette historien les pilotes américains
sont peu expérimentés les dommages
collatéraux sont alors très nombreux
cette nuit-là alors là j'ai eu très peur
d'un seul coup il y a eu un tremblement
terrible parce que il y avait environ
une centaine de bombardiers qu'on envoyé
près de 500 kg de bombes explosiv et et
incendiaire et et il y en a la moitié
qu' on touché les objectifs mais l'autre
moitié qui s'est dispersé un peu partout
Velpo beaujardin prébande avenue Gramont
tous ces quartiers sont touchés comme en
témoigne cette carte représentant les
impacts de bombes la rue Édouard
Vaillant est éventré la passerelle
Fournier détruite l'école Michelet à
reconstruire mais curieusement la Gard
de tour est sauvé extraordinaire il y
avait des des maisons effondrées sur la
chaussée les plaques des goûs soulevé
les fils des des tramo
abattus c'était quelque chose d'p
rentable le bilan humain est très lourd
140 victimes environ dont 70 situé dans
un abri près du pont d'arcool des
bombardements tour en a connu plusieurs
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale celui
des Allemands en 1940 qui privera le
vieux tour de sa partie centrale puis ce
des alliés en 1942
4 à la Libération 40 % de la ville est
détruit sans compter les secteurs
sinistrés t recevra alors la croix de
guerre